Guys, we know the fidget spinner fad has somewhat faded but, we still have some and so there's some things
we want to try with them. Mainly, we want to take fidget spinners and put them up against a block of ice.
I don't mean leaning up against the block of ice, I don't even mean throwing them like ninja stars at a block of ice, although it does sound kind of fun
What we're gonna do is take a bunch of fidget spinners, melt them down,
and then pour the molten metal down into the block of ice.
I'm hoping that by using nothing but melted fidget spinners,
we can replicate our aluminum explosion and destroy this block of clear ice.
Goodbye fidget spinners!
Well, That looks like a good amount of those
While our fidget spinners are melting in our foundry, let's prepare our ice to receive the molten metal.
There we go, that's nice and clear
Just give our holding container a couple of minutes over the fire so it's not cooling off our crucible too quickly.
Okay,
Three, Two, One
HAHAHA, hahahahaha,
YEAH!
There's just a blob of super heated aluminum
inside our block of destroyed ice!
That looks amazing!
Let's look at what's left at the bottom of this cup, fidget spinners are mostly made of aluminum
But the bearings inside them are not and I removed the bearings from some, I didn't
want to come out of all of them so I think what
We have down here is a bunch of slag made of a little bit of molten aluminum, and a lot of hot steel bearings.
Each one of these little circles here is a bearing from a fidget spinner, at least seven maybe
A few more, still just stuck down in the remaining aluminum I don't think they're gonna spin very well anymore let's go look at
That ice more that was amazing, okay?
so right here there's still this is the mark from the drill bit when i drilled the hole down into the block of ice
So when the aluminum went in there and exploded it like exploded
Sideways and sheared everything off but you can, still
See the little point, where the drill bit made its mark so it didn't explode down
Like at all it just exploded sideways and all of our aluminum
melted its way down, through the block of ice well not the block of ice anymore the remaining shards of ice
melted through our cord
here is the remains of the fidget spinners that so valiantly gave their lives to destroy this block of ice
i'm not sure which one is worse off the block of ice or the fidgets spinners they're, both pretty much gone
and Unrecognizable.
Guys we've got a bunch of these king of random branded fidgets spinners in six different varieties rather than melting them all down
We are giving, them, away all you have to do is pay for shipping
Guys, the fun's not over there's still more for you to see that little
Box up at the top will transport you directly to our last video and the box at the bottom will take you to what youtube
Thinks you should be watching next this bomb here in the center will subscribe you to our channel so you
Never, miss out on another video again, don't forget to ring that bell and we'll see you the next one talk to you then